[muzică]
Bună dimineața, dragi pescari! Suntem
din nou pe apă. Este ultima partidă din
2025. Suntem în decembrie. Dimineață a
fost foarte frig. Totul era înghețat.
Lansetele erau înghețate. Eu am ajuns de
ieri. Am ajuns de ieri în jurul orei
12:00. M am plimbat un pic pe canale. Am
fost pe Litcov. Am pescuit o oră pe
Litcov, dar venea mizerie pe apă. Veneau
frunze de tocate și îmi umplea firul.
După care am venit pe Pengusta. Peng
gusta am sondat un pic, am găsit o
cioată unde peștele
Mă uit, cred că am trăsătură în dreapta
sau e mizerie pe fir.
Am sondat mai multe cioate, am găsit
peștele pe o cioată efectiv băgat
subată, adică tot cantonat acolo. Am
pescuit în jur de două ore ieri am avut
o singură trăsătură din ciata respectivă
și mi a îndreptat cârligul pentru că
dau cu fir textil de 0,13 și cu cârlig
de 10 și atunci cumva mi l a mi l a
îndreptat. Am tras și un pic mai tare de
el pentru că venea o barcă și îmi era
frică să nu mi taie să nu mi taie firul.
Dădeam și aproape de ceată. L am forțat
un pic și am îndreptat cârligul, dar na,
asta este. Măcar am avut o trăsătură,
ceea ce a fost un curajator pentru mine
ca să vin și astăzi pe locul ăsta.
Astăzi abordez un pic diferit locul.
M am ancorat direct în curent, am
aruncat ancora și dau efectiv
până în ciată. Adică arunc. Ca să vă
explic un pic, pe partea dreaptă. Partea
dreaptă aici am cioată. În față, în față
am ceată. În stânga este cioată. Deci
cumva este o ceioată care vine
din dreptul copacului care se vede acolo
și se duce până pe până pe șenal, până
pe mijlocul canalului. Da. Și eu încerc
să dau până în cioată. Le am aruncat așa
din mână și acum aștept să văd să văd
care i treaba. Poate avem ceva poate
avem ceva trăsătură. Dacă n o să am
trăsătură, nicio trăsătură două ore
aici, o să mă mut pe o altă cioată, o să
găsesc o altă cioată și o să dau la fel
tot în ciată pentru că peștele tot este
cantonat în ciată, el nu se plimbă.
Curentul pe canal este destul de destul
de puternic îngusta.
Apa nu din filmare nu vă dați seama, dar
nu este tocmai să zic prea bună de
pescuit. Este un pic murdărică, dar am
riscat și am zis că o să pescuiesc dacă
tot am văzut peștele. Ia să vedem.
Stai să am trăsătură în dreapta. Ori e o
mizerie pe fir care tot coboară. Tot
coboară.
Așa. Bun. Pescuiesc cu momitoare cu
cârlige. Am început cu cârlige de 10 cu
cireșa de pe tort. N de pe momitor. O să
dacă o să am o să încep să am
prezentări. O să schimb un pic O să
schimb un pic stilul dând foarte aproape
de cioată. O să schimb și o să pun
tamburii cu firul de 0,55
ca să pot să dau și în ceată și aproape
de ceioată, să pot să țin bine de el și
să am și un pic de elongație. Eu acum cu
firul textil de 01,13 n am deloc
elongație. N am deloc. Este foarte rigid
tot ansamblul și este, să zic, este un
pic greu de scos peștele pentru că este
posibil să îi rubuza sau
să taie firul. Merge pescuit cu firul
textil. Când lucrezi cu frânele. Eu acum
am frânele strânse, sunt foarte puțin
date drumul ca să poate să ia foarte
puțin fir. Dacă
văd că o să am trăsături și nu mă
descurc cu firul ăsta, ce o să fac? O să
pun tamburi cu firul de 0,55 și o s dau
aproape de ciudată. Eu ieri am început
am început partida cu firul de 0,55 pe
Litkov și m am pus pe, mă rog, m am pus
pe un mal și am pescuit pe malul de
vizavi și pentru că curentul era
puternic, auzeam cum vâjia
cum vâjia firul în apă și atunci am
decis să pun tamburii cu firul textil.
Deși acum, sincer să vă zic, mi ar fi
trebuit un un fir de 0,35, dar din
păcate nu am la mine. Nici acasă nu am
pe tamburi alt tambur de rezervă cu
0,35, dar o să mi iau și o să mi fac
0,35 pentru că pentru perioada asta ar
fi fost ar fi fost suficient și pe
canale ca să nu vâjie atât de tare și să
pot să dau și niciodată să fie cât de
cât puternic.
Bun.
Iar nu știu dacă v am zis, în cazul în
care o să am trăsături pe momitor și o
să văd că este o frecvență bună, o să
schimb pe fir.
O să schimb pe plumb in line, pe plumb
pierdut și cu rig ca vara cu rig de șase
cu cârlig de șase de șase și plumbul
pierdut, iar rigul legat cu fir
cămășuit, adică să fie cât mai cât mai
rezistent ca să pot să dau aproape de
ciată sau chiar în ciată.
Bun, asta este. Acuma n avem de făcut
decât n avem de făcut altceva decât să
așteptăm.
Mă apuc să le împrospătez
și o să și schimb. O să bag două pe
plumb pierdut și pe bilă de 20 cu cârlig
de 6.
Hai!
Să vă mai arăt o schemă pe care o fac.
După ce am încărcat momitorul, cum v am
arătat în alte clipuri, am băgat peleta
în interior, am adăugat puțină nadă
deasupra, dar nu am strâns o. Efectiv am
pus o un pic
ca să se desfacă în coloana de apă și ca
să se desfacă foarte repede pe momitor
și să facă o dâră. ăă în curentul în
curentul apei, da? Adică să se activeze
și mai repede.
Mut locul. N am avut nicio trăsătură
aici. Mă duc puțin mai în față să mă uit
pe niște cioate. Dacă nu, o să mă întorc
din nou pe locul ăsta. O să mă uit din
nou pe ciudat aici. O să încerc să
abordez altfel, să mă pun la mal sau mai
știu eu, un loc mai jos. Mai aș duce și
acolo. Oricum, încă nu știu. Mă duc să
mă duc să caut mai sus să vedem. Poate
găsesc aici
am mutat pe un alt loc. Am găsit
peștele. Aici este un plop care a căzut
de pe mal, s a răsturnat. Cam până pe
aici este agățătura, după care urmează
o, să zicem, un culoar unde nu este
agățătură și după care iar este
agățătură în față. Este iar acolo sunt
ceva crenci. Iar peștele este de sub
lopul ăsta de aici, fix de fix de sub
mine și se duce se duce puțin în față,
după care se întoarce. Deci aici are un
comportament diferit. Probabil că se
duce în agățătura din șenal, după care
se întoarce din nou spre mo Da.
Hai să vedem, poate reușim să păcălimți.
Dragi pescari, prima zi de pescuit
este aproape gata.
Astăzi nu am avut absolut nicio
trăsătură.
De fapt, am avut două roșioare,
dar nu asta caut. M am mutat de pe locul
pe care am stat dimineață, unde găsisem
peștele. M am mutat pentru că n am mai
avut n am avut nicio trăsătură. Am venit
pe locul ăsta.
Am găsit peștele. Foarte mult pește.
comportament diferit față de locul de
dimineață. Aici, peștele, practic unde
sunt eu este cioata. Eu stau fix pe
cioată și în larg pe mijlocul canalului
mai este o ciată acolo.
Peștele pleacă de aici din de sub mine
din cioata asta se duce în cioata aia
după care se întoarce. Probabil fac
curând. Se duc doi acolo, vin doi aici.
Dacă dacă vă întrebați de unde știu
lucrul ăsta, mă uit cu sonda live. Am
aprins o. Am stat am stat cu ea aprins,
mă rog, cu sonarul aprins și m am uitat
m am uitat pe fund să văd comportamentul
pe care îl are peștele
și n am avut nicio trăsătură nici aici.
Am încercat tot felul de minciunele, tot
felul de lucruri, peletă afară peste
nadă și așa și așa am schimbat, am băgat
și în nadă. Prima dată am început cu
nadă fără pelete, fără fish meal, după
care am băgat fish meal, mai mult fish
meal. Efectiv nu am avut nici măcar o
trăsătură.
Peștele se vede pe sondă cum vine și stă
cu capul în jos. Deci merge pe substrat
și vine, stă cu capul în jos.
Normal, ar fi trebuit să am măcar doi
trei pești la la ce densitate de pește
este aici. Acum am o mare dilemă și nu
știu ce să fac. Chiar o să întreb
băieții pe grup să mă ajute un pic să mă
sfătuiască sau să vedem ce zic și ei. Nu
știu ce să fac dacă să vin. O să mai am
de pescuit mâine toată ziua și vineri
dimineață până pe la 9:30.
Dacă mâine să vin tot aici, pentru că am
găsit peștele, e clar că este aici și să
sper că o să l că o să se hrănească
mâine în seara asta, să i arunc câteva
bile
că poate să începe să se hrănească cu
ele și cumva dă de gust și începe să
caute să caute mâncare.
Sau mâine s o iau de la capăt să mă duc
pe alte canale. Ar mai fi o variantă
pentru mine, canalul lui Litkov. Unde s
a prins pește ieri, astăzi? Nu știu, n
am nicio informație.
Iar acolo pe canalul Litcof să mă pun pe
ceată cum sunt aici, să dau direct în
ciată pentru că ieri, ieri merg venea
mizerie pe pe fire.
Nu știu încă, nu sunt hotărât ce o să
fac. O să vedem, o să vedem până mâine.
O să mă sfătuiesc și cu băieții pe grup.
O să văd ce zice și Mihai, ce zice și
Costeluș. Adun așa mai multe informații.
Eu aș tinde un pic să stau tot pe locul
ăsta. Mie mi s a mai întâmplat o dată
așa anul trecut prin decembrie. Două
zile totusta, două zile
n am prins pește, deși
l am văzut pe sonar. Era peștele pe
sonar. M am uit m am plimbat pe toată în
gust a două zile. Nu am nu s a hrănit,
nu am reușit să prind pește. După care a
treia zi am prins peste 15 16 bucăți
într o singură zi și a patra zi la fel
am prins pește.
pe același loc unde i găsisem și unde nu
se hrăneau, unde am încercat să i
pescuiesc și nu se hrăneau. Da. Bun. Hai
să vedem. Nu știu, vedem mâine dimineață
să vă zic ce decizii am luat. Acum o să
las camera pornită. O să mai stau vreo
15 minute. Dacă intră vreun pește în 15
minute, o să l vedeți. Dacă nu, asta
este, o iau spre cazare și fac strategia
de la cazare.
Bună dimineața, dragi pescari. Suntem
din nou pe apă. Am schimbat strategia.
Ieri vă spuneam că sunt nehotărât. Nu
știu ce să fac. Dacă să merg în
continuare pe Ngusta să pescuiesc
peștele de acolo sau să plec pe Litcov
și
să o iau de la capăt să pescuiesc și să
încerc să găsesc loc pe Litkov și să
pescuiesc peștele de pe Litcov. Ei bine,
am decis să
vin pe Litcov.
O să vă povestesc puțin mai încolo care
au fost, să zicem așa,
motivele pentru care am decis să vin
aici. Astăzi vreau să testez un lucru.
Vreau să văd dacă
ce am gândit eu aseară, mă rog, împreună
cu ceilalți colegi pescari, dacă dacă
este adevărat și o să vă povestesc așa,
să vă zic cu lux de amănunte, să vă fac
o imagine de ansamblu despre ce s a
întâmplat ieri și ce se va întâmpla
astăzi dacă îmi ies lucrurile așa cum mi
am propus. Ok, am început partida. Sunt
pe Litcov.
Am luat doi garaj
până acum pe lanseta cea din partea
stângă pe care am pus o. Am pus o cumva
jos pentru că dau la fundul bărcii
foarte aproape de barcă. Peștii sunt sub
mine. Sunt băgați în Eu sunt ancorat
într o ciată. Sunt băgat cu botul într o
ciată.
Peștii sunt sub mine, stau în cioată și
ies un pic pe scenal, după care se
întorc înapoi. În continuare vine
mizerie pe fire, dar văd că nu este la
fel de deranjant ca prima zi în care am
pescuit aici o o oră. Ia uitați
trăsătură. Cred că e tot caras.
Și cumva e mai bine. Văd că deja nu mi s
a am deja cred că 25 de minute cu ele în
apă și văd că nu mi s au nu mi s au
umplut de mizerie. Ceea ce este ok dacă
scot la 40 de minute să curăț firele. Nu
este ceva nasol. Hai să vedem dacă e
mâncarea asta aici.
Nu știu dacă voi vedeți lanseta cea
mică. Ia.
Da,
e un caras frumușel.
Haideți să vi l arăt.
Hopa!
Uitați ce caraș
sunt lito.
Chiar
chiar e super. Bun. Deci cam asta o să
fac astăzi. O să încerc să pescuiesc
crapul. Văd că intră și caras. Asta e. N
am ce i face. Se pare căasul stă la un
loc cu crapul în momentul de față. Și
asta este. Mai prindem și caras și poate
intră și ceva crapi.
Așa, mă băieți, primul crap al partidei
este, mă.
Oho! Oho! Ia uitați ce se duce. Se duce
spre
Încerc să l țin, să știți, pentru că
sunt neînrangi.
Dacă se duce pe lar, n am o problemă.
Oho, uite ce frumos e.
Da, da.
Deci îl ajută și curentul.
Acuma trebuie să l aduc încet, să l las
să obosească aici și la suprafață și l
aduc încet. Nu mă grăbesc
pentru că am cârligeni mici
și nu vreau să
îl scap.
Deci se pare că teoria pe care am făcut
o
aseară
a cam dat rezultate
și o să vă povestesc ce s a întâmplat
ieri pentru că mi am dat seama
și
ce să facem noi
în alte partide.
Încerc să l aduc pe aici pe mijlocușor.
Mamă, dar ce frumos e, mă, băieți.
Nu știu cât are,
dar jur că e frumos.
Hopa, ușor.
Deci, agățat un pic de buză.
Să vedem și reușesc
să merg în barcă.
L am obosit bine. Nu mai are vlag în el
și cred că e la vreo 5 kg așa. Haide,
mă.
Foarte greu.
Foarte greu. Singur în barcă, băieți.
Bun,
am reușit.
Haideți să vă arăt.
Ia uitați ce animal am prins, bă băieți.
Ia uitați, băieți, pește frumos de
decembrie.
Superb.
Superb pe canale. Na, hai să i facem și
poză.
Așa. Hai să vă explic un pic care sunt
concluziile de ieri și astăzi. Ieri eu
am făcut o mare greșeală. Știți că
în generalizarea este cel mai important
lucru atunci când pescuim la crap. Nu
doar Delta Dunării, ci peste tot este
cel mai important lucru. Dar eu ieri ce
am făcut? Am și stați un pic ca să
vedeți că nu este neapărat doar
localizarea. Deci asta din experiența de
ieri.
Când am venit
marți am venit pe Litcov, am fost pe
Îngusta, pe Litcov am găsit câțiva
pești, venea iarbă pe fir, am plecat pe
Ngusta. Îngusta este canalul meu de
suflet, să zic așa. Îngusta ține pește
și de multe ori ține și pește mare. Bun,
m am dus m am dus pe îngusta. Am găsit
pe niște ciate pe care am mai pescuit
eu. Am găsit peștele acolo. Era tot
băgat în cioată, efectiv băgat în
cioată. M am pus vizavi, am lansat și în
două ore am avut o trăsătură pe care l
am scăpat. V am povestit, v am povestit
și ieri că l am scăpat. Bun. Asta mie mi
a dat încredere că peștele este acolo și
că pot să l pescuiesc a doua zi, deși
apa era murdărică. Era mai murdară decât
este pe Litkov. Nu era tulbure tulbure,
dar era un era murdărică, să zicem așa.
Pentru că am avut trăsătura aia, a doua
zi am fost tot acolo, am găsit peștii
tot acolo erau. Am stat cred că patru
ore, trei ore, patru ore, n am avut
nicio trăsătură. După care m am mutat pe
altă cio v am explicat ieri când dădeam
sub mine erau peștii, se duceau în
cioada din față și se întorceau. O
secundă, vă rog.
Așa, am pescuit ieri toată ziua acolo și
efectiv nu a vrut să pună să pună gura
și m am tot întrebat, bă, de ce nu se
hrănește? Care este situația? De ce de
ce de ce de ce nu se hrănește? Pentru că
eu l am localizat și în 99% din cazuri
când l am localizat am prins pește. Acum
ajungând la cazare, vorbind și cu Luci
Gazda unde dorm, vorbind și cu Mihai
Manea și cu Costeluș și cu mai mulți
pescari, luând informații și de pe
Litcov.
Mi am dat seama că apa fiind mai murdară
pe îngusta, peștele era acolo, era
cantonat în zona respectivă, dar nu avea
intenția de a mânca. Ok. Luci a mai zis
un lucru interesant, a spus că îngusta
este mai rece decât litcovul. De ce? Din
îngusta intră apă rece din direct din
Dunăre și pe Litcov vine apa caldă din
lacuri. Dar acuma este contraintuitiv să
te gândești la chestia asta pentru că în
lacuri normal apa se răcește mai repede
unde are adâncime mai mică față de
față de Dunăre unde normal cel puțin la
adâncime este o temperatură constantă se
răcește mai mai greu. Dar ideea este în
felul următor. Luci a zis că când a
venit tulbureal, a venit cu apă de sus
de la munte, cu tot felul de mizerii și
așa și a fost mai rece decât apa care
era deja în Dunăre, care era deja pe
deltă și atunci cumva îngusta este mai
rece decât litcovul și bineînțeles nu vă
gândiți acuma la diferențe mari de
temperatură, da? Poate ne gândim la un
grad, dar apa un pic rece, mai rece, cu
combinat cu bruma, care a fost ieri cu
frig foarte, na, a fost 2° noaptea și
combinat cu apa murdară, peștele nu s a
hrănit. Da, deci nu s a hrănit. În
schimb cei care au fost pe litcovieri au
prins pește. Deci s a peștele s a
hrănit, s a luat și la 7 kg și la 8 kg.
Adică peștele s a hrănit s a hrănit pe
Litcov față de un gusta. Litcovul este
alimentat, adică apa din Litcov vine
odată vine și din Sfântul Gheorghe, dar
vine și din lac, din Isac și Isășcel.
Ok? Și atunci apa este mult mai curată.
Bun. Acuma concluzia mea este în felul
următor. Chiar dacă ai localiza peștele
ar trebui să ții cont de mai mulți
factori. Deci nu doar că l am localizat
și am dat pe el și știți că eu v am spus
că folosesc Sonda Live și l localizez și
l văd efectiv și știu 100% că este crab.
Deci pe mine n are cum să mă minte să
zic, domnule, nu era peștele acolo, ni s
a părut sau na, lucruri de genul ăsta.
Deci eu știam 100%. Ia trăsătură. Hai să
vedem.
Oare a fi caras? Nu, nu e caras.
Sau Ba da, cred că da. E caras.
Este un caras mai frumușel.
Bun. Deci revenim. Vorbeam de vorbeam de
localizare. Deci ă din partida asta ă
bineînțeles la fiecare partidă învăț
câte ceva nou și mai ales atunci când nu
prind pește, atunci îmi pun mintea la
contribuție și îmi pun eu mie mai multe
întrebări și pun și pescarilor și le leg
între ele. Deci concluzia este în felul
următor că nu de fiecare dată când l ai
localizat este neapărat să prinzi pește.
Și asta este mai ales valabil în
nanotimpul rece. În anotimpul cald când
peștele se hrănește, dacă nu este
tulbure apa sau eu știu dacă nu scade și
este scade masi este o scădere masivă și
el este pe fugă de cele mai multe ori
prinzi pește dacă l ai localizat ia ieri
un caras
dar în partida de astăzi mi s a
demonstrat că chiar dacă am localizat
peștele nu am reușit să l pescuiesc.
Aici deja am avut am avut un crap ăă și
câțiva carași. Este clar că se hrănește.
Acuma l am localizat, este vorba de
abordare și este vorba, bineînțeles, și
de un pic noroc, că știți cum e. Ca și
pescare trebuie să avem și noroc pentru
că face parte din pescuit. Bun, cam asta
este. Cam asta este
ce am.
Stați că are o trăsătură
să ai mizerie de pe fire. Cam asta este
ce am gândit eu până acum și revin și cu
alte informații dacă dacă mai pun
lucruri cap la cap. U!
>> Da.
Deci a mai intrat un pește.
Ăsta cred că e un pic mai micuț.
Da. Deci, în timp ce vorbeam, a mai
venit un crap. Să vedem ce dimensiune
are. Nu s foarte agresivi, dar se
folosesc foarte mult de curent.
Curentul este puternic aici unde dau eu
și ei se folosesc de lucrul acesta. Se
lasă în curând și i aduci greu.
Hai să vedem. Asta este aia pe care doar
ce am aruncat o.
Încerc și să nu fac prea multă gălgie
pentru că v am zis peștele sub mine
și
acuma să încerc să l aduc ușurel.
Este pe la vreo 3 kg.
Am plecat cu minciogul, cu capul de
minciog mic la mine și mi e greu să i
scot pentru că nu mă așteptam să prind
pești prea mari. Mă așteptam să prin să
prind ciortani, dar uite că
ăla de mai devreme chiar mi a făcut
probleme pentru că n am putut să l iau.
Adică intrat greu mincioc. Da.
La 3 kg,
dar față de ieri când n am prins nimic
este foarte foarte bine.
Este un craf frumos. Dacă vă uitați
este un pic, nu știu, coada, este
ruptă. Cred că cumva a fost prins de
licea unui motor sau eu știu s au bătut
pe undeva. Oricum, superb. Este al
doilea pește,
ceea ce este foarte bine. De o oră n am
mai avut nicio trăsătură
decât caras. Uite și ăsta tot caras cred
că e. Ia să l scot.
Mamă, dar ce caras frumos.
Ia uitați, băieți, caras.
Ia uitați vă ce caras.
Frumos.
Vă ziceam că de oră n am mai avut nicio
trăsătură de crab. Doar caras.
M am uitat cu sonarul sub arcă. Nu mai
am crap sub mine, am doar caras. și
de o oră n am mai avut trăsături. Iar în
ora asta s au întâmplat niște lucruri.
Unu, eu când am prins peștii am făcut un
pic de gălăgie prin barcă și e posibil
să i fi speriat.
Doi, în partea stângă, în cioatele din
partea stângă sunt niște păsări mari cu
ciocul lung și gâtul lung, care se bat
pe acolo și fac gălăgie.
Și trei, în dreapta mea este un stol de
cormorani care este cantonat într o într
un plop undeva, nu știu, într un copac
și fac și ei gălăgie.
Acuma ce mă gândesc? Mă gândesc că
peștele a simțit lucrul ăsta și s a
mutat de aici. Deci efectiv sub mine am
doar caras. O să mă dezleg, o să ies cu
sonarul să văd dacă crapul este peșenal
sau ceva. Dacă nu, o să caut o altă
cioată unde nu sunt păsări. să caut
peștele în altă parte unde nu sunt
păsări pentru că aice de oră n am mai
avut nicio trăsătură și e clar că
peștele este destul de activ dacă l dacă
l găsești pentru că am avut două
trăsături una după alta când am ajuns.
Bun, mă dezleg și
mai arată o dată carasul ăsta. Uitați vă
și voi. Mă dezleg și ies să l caut.
Am zis că mă dezleg și ies să l caut.
Mam, bă, dar mi au înghețat mâinile.
Stau un pic să mă gălzesc.
Nici nu pot să mă dezleg.
Și înainte să plec, vreau să vreau să
modific o lansetă, cea care am pus o
doar pe bilă. Vreau să i pun și și să i
pun și la ea doar momitor cu cârlig
micuț,
dar după ce mă încălzesc un pic.
Am găsit o altă zonă. Este plin de crap
și aici.
Am crapi acolo în față la ceată. I am
văzut în față la ceată. Ieșeau din
ceată, mă rog, ceată
salce căzută.
Și chiar sub mine, eu sunt ancorat de o
altă de un alt copac care a căzut și sub
mine sunt o grămadă de crapi. Acuma să
vedem dacă reușim să păcălim câțiva. Cum
am lansat, am avut două trăsături de
caras.
Am scos un caras la asta și la asta am
mai avut o trăsătură, dar a scăpat în
dril.
Ia, asta i trăsătura.
Aha.
Pare a fi trăsătură aia
sau mizerie pe fir. Sper că vedeți. Nu
vedeți?
Uite asta de aici.
Nu, cred că e mizerie pe fir.
Te induce mult în eroare mizeria asta pe
fir pentru că se pune pe fir și când se
pune se lasă se lasă pe ea și după care
revine. Uite la asta mică am trăsătură.
Dacă vedeți cred că e tot caras
asta de aici din colț. Ia să vedem.
Hai să iau.
Nu, cred că a fost mizerie pe fir ceva
sau nu s a agățat.
Aha,
trăsătur aici era în ăsta. Bă, ăsta i
grap sigur. Da.
Deci ați văzut cinci minute. Mamă, mai
am una în stânga. Vai de capul meu.
Și ăla trage.
Încerc să l țin pe ăsta un pic
și acolo.
Dar acolo pare a fi caras.
că încerc să l aduc pe ăsta mai repede.
Ăsta i micuț, nu e mare.
Am dus repede.
Să vedem eu vreo prostie.
Nu
cum plic, draut
să l scot așa pentru că aveam trăsătură
și acolo.
Ăsta i mai micuț,
1, J.
Ia uitați
un ciortan.
Un ciortan care peste trei patru ani o
să fie
o captură minunată.
Doar ce m am mutat și deja au început să
tragă crapi. Dar să vedeți ce e sub
mine. Eu mă tot uit sonar. Deci sub mine
e vai de capul meu.
Uitați trăsătură.
Ăsta pare a fi caras, să știți.
Da, caras este.
Ce ușor
așa caras frumos.
Și cred că mai am unul în stânga.
Asta e. Iarna prins tot ce vine.
Se joacă un pic cu el. Să l iau din
țăcăneală. Ia să vedem.
Sau e mizerie pe fir? Nu mi dau seama.
Nu e trăsătură sigur.
Lasă
nu, mă, unde te duci?
Ia vezi, mă, că mi a luat firul.
Încurcat, mă, ăsta, mă.
M [râsete]
ia uite, mă, ce mi caras ăsta
este. Treaba este un pic nasoală.
Peștele stă sub mine, stă practic în
spatele cioatei. Eu n am cum să l
abordez,
n am cum să mă bag așa aici și să dau
efectiv sub mine. Pe malul opus nu pot
să mă pun că vine multă mizerie pe pe
apă.
Tot ce sper este să rămână peștele acolo
pe care l am văzut, dar și acolo este
același lucru pentru că nu pot să l
abordez în spatele cioatei. Trebuie să l
cumva îl abordez înaintea ciatei cu
lanseta din stânga, lângă cevată cu
lanseta a doua și tot așa. Am încercat
să dau cu cea mică din partea stângă, o
am aici lângă barcă, dar peștele este
efectiv sub mine. Deci cumva peștele stă
în spatele cioatei, se lasă puțin în
curent, după care revine. Cam asta am
văzut eu pe sonar. Este diferit
comportamentul față de primul loc unde
am fost.
Hai să vedem, poate se mișcă totuși un
pic și scoatem ceva.
Nu știu, vedem. Dacă nu am nicio
trăsătură timp de o oră, văd. Ori îl
abordez aici. Încerc caut o soluție să l
abordez aici. Ori dacă nu caut alt loc
pentru că nu, adică ați văzut trăsătura
trebuie să vină instant. Deci dacă
peștere este acolo și e ok, ai plasat
montura unde trebuie, în 10 15 minute
trebuie să ai trăsătură. Când m am pus
aici, a fost un pește acolo, am dat pe
el, a tras n a fost mare, dar mi a dat
curaj, dar văd că deja de 30 de minute n
am avut decât caras.
Hai să vedem.
[muzică]
Aha. Hai să vedem.
Nu mi dau seama dacă e un caras mai
măricel sau e crap. Ia să vedem.
Lung. Crab. Nu e mare.
Ăștia micuții sunt cei mai agresivi.
Un ciordănaș.
Ia să vedem. Fac eu o prostie. Hop.
Așa.
Am mai scos un ciortan, mai stau, am
reprospătat toate lansetele. Mai stau 15
minute. Dacă nu am nicio trăsătură
de pește mai mare decât ciortanii ăia,
mă mut. Este pește mare, mai mare sub
mine, dar n am cum să pescuies să l
pescuiesc. M am tot gândit cum să fac,
cum să fac. N am cum să mă bag aici
pentru că este o creangă care iese și
vine pe sub arcă și atunci n am cum să n
am cum să lansez. Pe partea opusă vizavi
nu pot să mă pun pentru că vine multă
iarbă pe fire și atunci o să mi ia o să
mi ia firele o să umple de mizerie. De
fapt sunt frunze tocate, nu e iarbă
și na, n am ce să fac. O să mă mut și
caut alt loc în cazul în care nu reușesc
aici
și pescari. Hai să vedem.
Deci, după ce am împrospătat,
a mai venit unul. Da, cred că e la fel
ca ceilalți. Sunt frați toți.
Dacă e la fel, am plecat de aici.
Caut alt loc.
Da, așa pare
tot așa.
Mam i a căzut din gură și mi a sărit
bine că nu mi a venit în față.
Mă mut, nu mai stau. Deci aici am prins
trei trei ciortani. E clar că asta este
mărimea lor de acolo. Probabil că dacă
aș mai sta aș mai lua câțiva, dar
poate intră ceva mai mare. Mă duc să mai
caut.
M am mutat pe alt loc. Aici am văzut
pești ceva
mai mari.
Locul arată diferit față de celelalte
locuri.
Eu sunt ancorat de un copac care a căzut
în apă și aici în fața mea este relativ
curat în față, dar sunt câteva mici
agățături câteva mici crenguțe căzute de
la copacii de la copacii de aici de
lângă noi din partea stângă și peștii
efectiv stăteau în crengile respective,
ieșeau de acolo, se plimbau. Ă
hai să vedem ce facem și aici. Poate
reușim să scoatem câțiva
mai scump. Dear
>> e am, dar e micță.
>> A, salut! Salut!
Cum îi
>> am luat unul de 7 kg,
>> atât?
>> Unul de trei și încă trei de 15 J așa.
Dar m am mutat de trei ori. Acuma doar
ce am ajuns aici.
>> Da.
Mai stai și mâine.
>> Mâine două ore și atât.
Tu ce faci acum? Ai venită dacă am
familia? Au plecat cu
>> A, ok.
>> Foarte bine.
>> Hai, ne auzim. Ciao. Pa.
>> Mersi. La fel.
Aici n am avut nicio trăsătură.
Este pește. Este pește și sub mine și
când eu am venit era și în față.
Acum este ora cred că 1:30, aproape de
2:00. Ia să mă uit să văd.
Este 2:10, deci
este posibil să aibă și ore de hrănire.
Posibil ca dimineață până în ora 10:00
11:00 să se fi hrănit bine când am prins
peștii și acum o să fie o pauză. Așa că
o să rămân în continuare pe acest loc. N
o să mă mut. O să rămân până până târziu
pentru că am văzut pești mai mari și
poate reușesc să scot unul, poate
reușesc să păcălesc unul. Dacă nu, mai
am două ore mâine, poate mai scot și
mâine doi trei pești dimineață. Și cam
asta a fost partida. Hai să vedem, poate
mai scoatem ceva.
Am avut trăsătură.
>> Auzi, aia din dreapta. Ia, ia, ia, ia.
Stai, stai, stai, stai, stai, stai,
>> stai. Așa să vedem ce e.
Oho! Ohoh!
În sfârșit, dragi pescari, a venit un
pește după locul ăsta.
Nu mi dau seama cât de mare e, dar
î era un pic teamă că nu că n o să prind
ceva aici, dar văd că
văd
>> așa e foarte agresiv.
Așa, mă. Hai.
Vino pe lateral.
Deci ăștia mii sunt foarte foarte
agresivi.
Mic e pe la vreo 2 kg.
Dar bine că a venit unul, că mă gândeam
să mă mut. Oho, nu i chiar micuț.
Ha! Ia,
ia să vedem, mă, că mă înșeală pe mine
peștele ăsta câteodată.
Dar n am obosit, mă.
Bună.
>> Ce drill? Zici că e vară,
că e pe la vreo 3 kg, așa.
Superb.
Gata, aici rămân. Nu mă mai mut.
Mă gândeam să mă mut, dar nu n are sens.
Hai că a obosit.
Să vedem.
Gata.
Ce m a obosit. Zici că Zici că i vară.
Așa a fost drillul. Pe cuvântul meu.
Da. Bun. Deci a venit unul
de acum. Tot ce intră este bonus.
Deci așa arată mustăciosul. Eu zic că
are 25.
A venit după vreo 40 de minute, o oră de
când m am pus aici.
Mai rămân aici un pic și vedem ce facem
și mâine.
[muzică]
Hai că parcă m a înviorat un pic peștele
ăsta.
Chiar voiam să mă mut,
dar văzusem pește aici, văzusem pești
mai măricei și sub mine sunt pești mai
mari și
parcă nu mi venea să plec de pe locul
ăsta. Am zis mai devreme că este posibil
să aibă ore de hrănire. Vorbeam cu
Costeluș la telefon și mă sfătuiam și cu
el și i am zis: Bă, nu știu ce să fac,
să mă duc acolo, să mă întorc pe locul
unde am mai prins să rămân aici, că am
văzut pește mare. Costelu și a zis: „Du
te acolo." Z am zis: „Păi da, am văzut
pește mare și când când vorbeam noi la
telefon a venit a venit trățătura.
Așa că așteptăm. Între timp a mai venit
un pescar acolo. Ușor! A mai venit un
pescar acolo. Este un pescar care merge
mult în Delta Dunării, Valentin Găscanu.
Probabil mulți dintre voi îl știți de pe
TikTok.
Astăzi mi a zis că a avut două trăsături
dimineață de pești mare, dar i arat. Și
cam atât.
Acum, na, vedem ce face și el. Dacă
prinde și el acolo, cu atât mai bine că
îmi dă mie curaj să rămân aici. Iar
mâine, mâine nu știu, mâine nu știu ce
să fac, dar oricum o să vin și o să caut
peștele. Deci nu, nu mai stau după el.
Nu mai stau pe locuri cu potențial și să
stau mult acolo. Efectiv mă duc și l
caut. Astăzi strategia asta a funcționat
mai bine decât decât ieri. Am prins până
acum trei pești. De fapt sunt șase pești
în total. Trei sunt ciortani la 1,G și
unul la 7 kg și doi la 2 kg treiași.
Ceea ce este foarte bine pentru o zi de
decembrie în care iară vinzile. Acuma dă
să iasă așa un pic soarele pe apuz, dar
nu ne au unorat cu prezența astăzi.
Hai să vedem ce mai este.
[muzică]
Băieți, hai să discutăm un pic despre
partida despre partida noastră. Mai am
jumătate de oră și o să plec la cazare
și mâine o să am doar două ore de
pescuit. Nu știu dacă o să pot să discut
așa pe lar pentru că o să stau mult pe
pescuit. Poate reușesc și mâine să scot
ceva. Bun. Ideea este în felul următor.
Am ajuns, am ajuns marți. Marți am venit
pe Litkov. Am vrut să Am vrut să văd
dacă este peștele aici. Am găsit peștele
pe ceată. Am încercat să pescuiesc și
a fost a venea iarba pe fire și n am mai
n am mai pescuit. M am dus pe îngustă,
am găsit peșele și acolo am avut o
trăsătură și care mi a dat mi a dat
curaj ca să mă duc și a doua zi. A doua
zi am stat toată ziua pe îngusta. N am
avut nici măcar o trăsătură. M am mutat
de două ori, deși am găsit am găsit
peștele de două ori. Nu am avut absolut
nicio trăsătură.
Concluzia a fost că apa era murdară și
chiar dacă am reușit să l localizez,
peștele nu a vrut să se hrănească. Nu am
reușit să l păcălesc absolut deloc.
Absolut deloc. Bun, astăzi am prins șase
pești, dintre care unul la 7 kg și doi
doi pe la vreo 3 kg. Restul de trei
ciortani la 1,g.
Poate chiar 1 kg. Bun.
Haideți să vă zic și cu ce am pescuit în
partida asta, pentru că este destul de
important. Vreau să vă explic un aspect
cu minciunelele
și să vă prezint și noua nadă care încă
nu se află pe nu se află la vânzare.
Este de fapt este
baza aceeași nade pe care am avut o până
acum. Doar că am îmbunătățit o. Am
adăugat două ingrediente noi și am făcut
o să se coleze mai bine și o să aibă și
o tentă ușoară de culoare. Nu știu cât
de bine o să se vede pe cameră. Deci o
să fie tot grunjoasă, tot
tot cu particule mari.
Aici am nada de căpșună. Este un pic,
hai să zicem așa, rozalie. duce spre
roșu un pic și este combinată cu
peletele de 5 mm și o să fie în trei
variante. O să fie verde usturoi, roșu
căpșună și galben secret aroma. Bun,
asta este nada pe care eu cu care eu am
pescuit am pescuit
toată partida asta și la cârlig am
început cu am început am început cu
peletele de 10 mm.
Trăsătura, prima trăsătură pe care am
avut o pe îngusta a fost la peletă de 10
mm
și după care când ne am dat seama că
peștele nu se prănește absolut deloc și
este foarte foarte apatic, am trecut la
niște minciunele. Da, dar astea sunt
niște minciunele un pic speciale pe care
o să le avem și noi în portofoliul
nostru. Sunt niște minciunele moi. Da.
Deci sunt foarte, foarte moi. Dacă
vedeți, apeși pe ele. Sunt foarte moi și
sunt oarecum wafter uri. Da, adică nu nu
ridică cârligul, se ridică doar ele și
cumva păcălesc peștii. Dar haideți să vă
explic care este care este șmecheria, de
ce le zic eu minciunele și care este de
fapt logica. Gândiți vă că voi aruncați
momitorul. Aici aveți nadă și dacă noi
dacă eu v am zis până acum peleta s o
băgăm deasupra ca atunci când peștele
vine să se hrănească de pe momitor să
prima opțiune să fie peleta, adică
cireașa de pe tor pentru că așa am
denumit o. Acum mecanica este diferită.
Deci avem nada pe momitor aici avem
minciunica împreună cu cârligul și nu le
mai băgăm în momitor. Le aruncăm pur și
simplu fără să le băgăm în momitor. Și
momitorul o să cadă pe substrat.
Minciunica o să fie luată de curent și o
să vină în curent. Toată nada se desface
de pe monumitor îți creează o dâră în
jos, în aval, pe nu știu, depinde cât se
duce, depinde cât de tare este, cât de
tare este curentul. Mai e și în spatele
la lansete, poate mai vine vreun pește.
Și ce se întâmplă? Minciunica rămâne pe
dâra respectivă. Da. Când peștele este
foarte apatic și nu se hrănește deloc,
el dacă dă de o masă gratuită va
încerca, va din curiozitate va lua, dar
el efectiv nu se va hrăni. El, intenția
lui nu este să se hrănească, mai ales
acum când apa este foarte foarte rece.
Da. Și ce se întâmplă pe dâra
respectivă, unde este praful acela și
particulele? El vine și ciugulește un
pic. Da? Și dă de minciunică. Aici poate
să fie două variante. Una, vede
minciunica că este acolo și se mișcă.
flutură un pic și din curiozitate o ia o
ia în o ia în buz, o aspiră pentru că
voi știți că peștele este crapul este un
este un pește curios și doi, efectiv din
întâmplare cât el absoarbe pe acolo
particulele respective, ia minciunica în
ia minciunica în gură. Da, deci doar la
aceste minciunele am prins am prins toți
peștii de 8 mm. Asta cred că este de 8
mm și de 15 mm. O să le avem și noi în
portofoliu și cred că chiar așa o să le
numesc minciunele
[râsete]
pentru că
efectiv fraieresc peștii. Da.
Cam cam asta cam astea sunt noutățile.
Nada probabil că o să fie o să fie
valabilă de la începutul anului la noi
pe site. Iar minciunelele nu știu să vă
zic când le vom le vom băga pentru că
vreau să îi facem exact textura aceasta,
dacă vedeți. Da, adică să fie foarte
foarte moi. Sunt sunt se pot folosi și
pe direct pe cârlig, adică băgate direct
pe cârlig și pe fir de păr. Eu le am
folosit pe fir de păr. Mie îmi place pe
fir de păr, dar se pot băga și direct pe
cârlig. Ok, ele sunt foarte moi. O să
fie în diferite arome, dar o să vedem.
Așa. Iar în legătură cu partida mea,
mâine mai am încă
două ore de pescuit. O să vin tot aici.
Astăzi o să încerc să fac o mică
șmecherie. O să nădesc locul acesta
pentru că am văzut pește mare pe el și o
să l nădesc. Pot să i dau câteva mâini
de bile ca să rămână să rămână aici pe
substrat și poate cine știe îl îl ținem
aici și l stârnim un pic să se
hrănească. Dacă dă de o bilă și mănâncă
o bilă, poate reușim să l să l stârnim
să se hrănească. Ce a căzut?
>> Am crezut că am avut o trăsătură, dar a
căzut găleata. Așa. Bun. Deci când plec
o să fac o să fac o nădire și cam asta
este. Mai am 10 15 minute de stat, după
care o iau spre cazare. Neața, dragi
pescari. Ultimele ore de pescuit. De
fapt, ultima oră și jumătate. Acum doar
ce am reușit să mă instalez. Până am
ajuns aici, ceață
s a făcut 8:30. La ora 10:00 trebuie să
plec pentru că la 11:30 maxim trebuie să
fiu la parcare la Nufăru ca să scot
barca.
Băiatul care mă ajută cu barca unde țin
unde țin barca parcată trebuie să plece
la ora 12:00 și atunci am promis că o să
ajungă mai devreme.
Nu știu ce să zic. N am mari speranțe
pentru dimineața asta. Am doar o oră
jumătate la dispoziție.
Cred că o să apuc să schimb de trei ori.
M am uitat cu sonarul. Peștele s a mutat
un pic și pare că stă în spatele
cioatei. Ieri am stat pe locul acesta,
dar am stat băgat într o cioată și eram
ancorat de bot și m am lăsat în curent
și pescuiam practic în spatele bărcii.
Da. Acum când am venit și am sondat
toată toată zona, pe zona unde eu
pescuiam ieri nu era niciun pește. Mă
rog, am văzut câțiva carași. În schimb,
peștele era băgat în cioata în cioata
din partea stângă, adică acolo unde
aveam eu barca ieri și oricum îi vedeam
sub barcă și ieri, deci erau și acolo,
doar că erau și în față. Da. Așa că m am
pus vizavi, deși e un pic, cum să zic
eu, un pic greu să pescuiești acum
pentru că este curent puternic și eu nu
mi dau, nu, nu reușesc să dau monturile
acolo unde am văzut peștii, pentru că
peștii erau cumva în spatele cioatei,
adică cum vine cum vine cioata așa, deci
cum vine, stai să văd dacă scri bine.
Cum vine cioata așa din mal, peștii erau
aici și eu nu pot să pescuiesc acolo,
dar cumva dau pe lângă ea, dau aproape
de ea în fața ei și în spatele ei, în
speranța în care peștii vor ieși un pic
de acolo, se vor plimba. Bun, o oră și
jumătate,
poate reușesc să scot ceva, dacă nu
reușesc să scot, asta asta a fost
partida.
Dar hai hai să nu fiu prea pesimist și
să zic că s a terminat. Așa că Se joacă,
se joacă. Mai am o oră jumătate să vedem
ce se întâmplă.
Dragi pescari, intrăm în ultimele 30 de
minute.
Le scot din nou, le lansez.
Până acuma le am lăsat pe toate lângă
ceată. Ce o să încerc cu cele din
dreapta o să încerc să le dau un pic mai
spre șenal, poate chiar pe șenal. Cea
din stânga de tot, cea mică, la fel pe
șenal. și cele două direct peă ultima
încercare. Dacă nu acasă.
Gata, dragi pescari, asta a fost partida
mea. 10 minute mai am de stat și am
plecat. Îmi strâng un pic prin barcă
lucrurile. Las lansetele în apă.
Dacă mai intră ceva, bine, dacă nu, nu.
A fost o partidă superbă, din punctul
meu de vedere.
A fost și o partidă dificilă, a fost
frig, mi au înghețat mâinile, mai ales
dimineața când ajungeam și băgam mâna în
apă, efectiv simțeam cum furnică
degetele, pielea.
Dar cu toate astea, cu toate astea a
fost a fost frumos. Mie asta îmi place.
Îmi place pescuitul extrem. Îmi place
pescuitul atunci când nu sunt mulți
pescari pe apă, când este liniște. N au
trecut foarte multe bărci, nu m au
bălăngănit prea mult.
Turiști nu sunt. Deci, din punctul meu
de vedere, este o perioadă perfectă de
pescuit. Peștele, din păcate, sau hai să
zicem, e normal să nu se hrănească.
Peștele este un animal cu sânge rece și
temperatura pe care o are apa asta o are
și el.
Iar metabolismul lui scade foarte mult
în momentul în care apa este rece, nu
mai poate să digere și atunci nu se mai
hrănește.
Se hrănește. este așa oportunist. Dacă
găsește ceva se mai hrănește, dacă na,
ceva micuț, ceva un praf, o larvă, un
viermișor, lucruri de genul ăsta, dar nu
se hrănește ca vara.
Partida mea se încheie cu șase pești și
câțiva carași.
Au fost trei crapi de 1,g, un crab de 7
kg și
un și doi de 3 kg. Faptul că am prins un
crab de 7 kg m a bucurat foarte mult,
mai ales pe canale, unde pe canale
peștii mari sunt mai rari.
Un crab de 7 kg, zicea Costeluș, un crab
de 7 kg prins pe canale e ca și cum ai
prinde un 10 plus pe navigabil.
În prima zi
am făcut greșeala de m am pescuit pe
Ngusta. Dacă veneam de prima zi pe
Litcov și căutam peștii pe Litcov,
probabil că aveam rezultate mai bune.
Dar ăsta este pescuitul. Din din asta
învățăm. Eu am învățat din asta. Am
învățat că atunci când condițiile sunt
mai bune într o anumită zonă să mă duc
în zona respectivă și să nu încerc eu să
fac
imposibilul acolo
acolo unde nu se poate.
În a doua zi am venit pe Litkov, am
găsit peștele, efectiv am făcut
pescuitul ăla de iarnă autentic în care
vânezc peștele, în care cauți peștele.
Ați văzut pe filmare în prima ceată, la
prima ceată unde la primul loc unde am
fost, am luat doi pești aproximativ unul
după altul.
Iar după aia mi s au mutat peștii. Dacă
aș fi rămas acolo toată ziua, probabil
aș mai prins nimic. Și uite așa m am
mutat de trei ori ieri pe locul pe loc m
am mutat de trei ori ieri, iar acum
dimineață când am ajuns
datorită timpului
nu am stat să caut peștele mai mult.
Sincer, ceva îmi spunea să mut locul
acesta, pentru că n am mai văzut peștii
așa cum i am văzut ieri. Aveam mari
speranțe când am plecat de la cazare că
locul o să țină pește cum îl ținea și
el, dar
se plimbă. Se plimbă. Deci peștele era
nu era o densitate atât de mare cum am
văzut ieri și era băgat în cioata în
cioata din partea stângă, dar efectiv nu
a vrut să nu a vrut să pună să pună
gura. nu a dat de minciunelele mele.
Dacă aș fi avut mai mult timp la
dispoziție, probabil aș fi căutat o altă
zonă sau m aș fi dus pe locul unde am
pescuit ieri dimineață
să caut peștii, să văd dacă găsesc pești
acolo. Dar, na, asta este. Într o oră și
jumătate, două, nu poți să faci prea
multe.
Cam asta a fost, dragilor. Este ultima
partidă din luna decembrie. Mă bucur
foarte mult că am prins pește. Ăsta este
pescuitul. Ă vă readuc aminte ă
pescuitul este despre ă în primul rând
relaxare, mai ales în Delta Dunării,
relaxare vizitarea locurilor, eu știu
descoperirea lucrurilor noi. Cel puțin
asta este asta este ăsta este pescuitul
pentru mine, iar peștele pentru noi este
bonus. Și vă mai zic încă o dată, pește
nu se prinde non stop. Da, dacă vedeți
partidele alea în care prinzi pește din
orice direcție, în orice poziție, acele
partide sunt rare. Ok? Ăsta este
pescuitul normal. O zi poți să prinzi, o
zi poți să nu prinzi, după care a treia
zi poți să prinzi iar. Acum, în funcție
și de timpul pe care îl petreci pe apă,
de timpul pe care îl petreci în Delta
Dunării. Bun, dragilor, ce să vă zic? Vă
urez sărbători fericite pentru că
urmează sărbătorile, urmează Crăciunul,
vine și Revelionul
și să ne vedem cu bine. Iar dacă aveți
întrebări vă rog să mi lăsați în
comentarii și nu uitați să lăsați și un
like, să distribuiți acest clip dacă v a
plăcut și ne revedem la anul. Eu sper
din ianuarie să încep deja să ies pe
apă. Vă salut și vă doresc fir întins.